of I can't I can't imagine having my
human rights and then my freedom
stripped away from me it's a frightening
frightening [ __ ] thought I do not
survive in prison bro it's smaller than
this in this room see I came to sell
some ways much smaller I would say like
cut in half like this is probably two
cells cut in half and you have a toilet
on the back wall and then you had the
bunk bed that's it walls that's crazy
yeah and then you have your your your uh
your celly your you know your other
person who you're sharing a cell with
and you taking a [ __ ] man you just got
to sit there while somebody's taking a
[ __ ] yes since my worst nightmare ever
dude
hey everybody put your paws on somebody
real quick hell no man now though you're
your biggest your strongest weapon as a
CEO is your pen oh I'm gonna write you
up yo straight up and they take away a
little bit [ __ ] that they would say yeah
man and and and my thing was like when
you first go in they tell you like when
you first go in you got to be hard you
got to be a cop you got to be a Robocop
if they would say like you got to be
Stern I take advantage of you yeah so
especially like looking like me I'm 18
years old too and like I was they was
just like new boots pretty boy Chris
Brownlee they was talking all types of
[ __ ] it was an inmate that saw me in
solitary confinement he was like he saw
me through his little window I just
heard him holler out
Alicia Keys Alicia Keys the whole [ __ ]
well and that [ __ ] you know who didn't
hear you dumb [ __ ] family there was
hollering Alicia Keys and lieutenant was
like well sounds like they're hollering
at you Sosa that's [ __ ] funny and I
hollering at me cuz they called me
Mariah Carey okay I was just like man it
was a it was some [ __ ] so whenever I got
armed and I was really like trying to be
hard like I'm like no just so that they
would I would get that respect
like I'm not playin around you know I
mean like [ __ ] that new boots [ __ ]
whatever whatever like no it's a serious
so I would take every little thing
things that like you would just let
slide just whatever
I'll tell me y'all let me see your ID
they play yo whoa whoa whoa wait we do
this all time
give me your ID I would do that I didn't
write them up there's a shitload of
paperwork for nothing yeah I would just
I would just do it just so that at the
end of the day I give it back to them
and I'm not a man don't do that [ __ ]
when I'm working because the next time
I'm gonna actually write your ass up so
it would be things like that of like you
have to there's no got to get to it
because then it got to a level of like
they would come in there Bly I don't
know no you don't officer so I dunno so
you know me like cool keeping them cool
and then I got to loosen up be myself
you still have authority but still be
like come on man you know you're
supposed to be doing that stuff like
that
it can't be like that at first no no no
cuz you know they'll just run over you
bro it's like it's like because you got
facial hair I don't got facial hair dude
it's [ __ ] clean-shaven and CEO really
well you can have a mustache it's a
union job so like union job you should
keep a mustache but I can't that bro I
got six like I got like two catfish
tears coming down my face they be
clowning me all day call me baby face
butt cheek face all of the stuff yeah
really start to UM I just thought man
she was wild in there Brock got a kid
there was another time the inmates
[ __ ] trolled me so [ __ ] bad bro I
can't believe this [ __ ] happen but so I
I got had to work showers right and so
there has to be an officer inside the
showers to make sure there's no [ __ ]
[ __ ] going on right or any fights or
whatever guy [ __ ] yeah and so I was
just making jokes before shit's real huh
okay yeah yeah and I'm upon way you know
that [ __ ] like [ __ ] the whole-- like
drop the soap yeah the the fact that the
inmates say this [ __ ] when they it may
say yeah whatever that's why Johnson
drops the soap I'm like yo we're
actually in prison so anyway I'm working
showers right and then an inmate he [ __ ]
he'd he convinced me he'll just like a
man I know is your first time working
showers but you just throw your shades
on easy work call it a day
you know three shades aren't any worry
about it you sit there we'll be in and
out right and so I was like I kind of
took it up like you know I've been there
for a little minutes my first time doing
I was all right cool [ __ ] it
shades on I'm chilling so I'm sitting in
the showers man shades on and we go and
I get an officer comes and breaks me
like he comes in light you know and so
he pulls me I said social come I say
alright come on he's like why are you
why are you that the minmei's tell you
to put the shades on man and I was like
I was like no I'm not I'll put them on
my selfies like nobody puts shades on in
the in the showers I was like why he's
like the inmates tell you that [ __ ] to
make it so that you look like you're
you're trying to look at their dicks but
so you don't get caught you wear the
shades so you could be looking at dick I
know they know that the officers that
we're shades you're just trying to look
at dicks says so they [ __ ] with you and
I was like oh I just like slowly taking
my glasses up I wasn't looking at you
know the rest of my Scottish [ __ ] movie
man and I remember when I got back like
from my break the showers were already
done but I went back to the cell bug
[ __ ] I was just like [ __ ] locked down
for the rest of the day [ __ ] like
[ __ ] yeah hey Robert past that dude [ __ ]
yourself look man it was like that so
you got the shades you still got the
shades like [ __ ] [ __ ] man too much
in prison then I'm not you got me that's
[ __ ] funny that's hilarious if you
were a [ __ ] correctional officer it
was a random it was hella rap before
that I was a I was working drive-through
at McDonald's it was like what the [ __ ]
jump
how does that happen okay 18 so the jump
so the jump happened like this
alright I had I went to college for like
two weeks
dropped out smart guy was it [ __ ]
wouldn't yeah and then I will put his
name on a piece of paper left real shiny
too many [ __ ] questions that's really
what happened it was actually I opened
up a new [ __ ] textbook and I just
like the smell of the paper I was like
oh my god this [ __ ] for another four
years
let me [ __ ] them so got a sentence so I
went back so I went back to
live my mom's and we went got me a job
at McDonald's